[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without me hey everybody welcome
to the hundredth episode of the
minimalist podcast you probably hear a
bunch of background noises during this
quick intro that's because we're
recording this brief intro in the
Phoenix Airport we're in the middle of
tour right now speaking of being on tour
we're getting ready to announce our
Australia and New Zealand tour dates if
you want to be the first to know about
that head on over to the minimalists com
get on our email list and you'll be the
first to know actually the people who
are absolute first to know are our
patreon supporters if you're interested
in being a patreon supporter you'll have
access to the presale tickets for our
Australia and New Zealand events you
head on over to patreon comm slash the
minimalists to other things that are
going on right now I'm about to teach my
last writing class of the year and it's
actually my last writing class for a
long time it's called how to write
better it's a two-hour online workshop
where I answer questions I also sort of
dissect my entire writing process and
give you the resources that have helped
me the most over the years the best
books and and and the best direction
that I've gotten over the course of the
last decade or so how to write better
org is where you can go to sign up for
that workshop if you're interested and
also Ryan and I are working with a whole
slew of simplicity experts on something
called a simple year in 2018 it's it's
12 months of guided simplicity and what
we're trying to do is we're working with
a bunch of experts on different areas
and so if you're interested in
simplifying your life and 2018 head on
over to the minimalists com a slash
simple year and you can find out all the
details about that each month we cover a
different topic from travel to
decluttering and food and the month that
Ryan and I work on is gift-giving so we
talk about the most effective and
beneficial ways to approach gift-giving
in 2018 if you're interested and a
little guided simplicity
we don't think you have to buy anything
in order to simplify your life but we
know some people need some guidance head
on over to the minimalists comm slash
simple year you can find out all the
details over there all right we hope you
enjoyed this 100th episode of the
minimalists podcast we'll see you soon
welcome to the middlemost podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Millburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists live in Vancouver
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you we we used
to take phone calls but we have a
microphone up here so don't call us you
can come right up to this microphone and
as the line is forming what a day it has
been Ryan oh my goodness men
unbelievably [ __ ] it started out so nice
and then those damn Canadians ruined
everything was it it was a foggy day
like any other day in Vancouver hey hey
I didn't mean that pejorative we lived
in Missoula Montana for the last five
years we know exactly about the Pacific
Northwest anyway
we were out we were out here doing sound
check at 5:20 p.m. and I know the time
specifically because it's on the police
report and we're doing sound check and
someone left the back door propped open
and all of a sudden we're getting ready
to go to dinner it's 5:35 p.m. I go back
there
Jessica was with us she runs all our
social media and fixes Ryan's hair
occasionally and she's I can't find my
bag and I'm like Jess it's right there I
just saw it like literally we did
soundcheck I went back to use the
restroom her bag was there I came out we
set the chairs where they were gonna be
we have a very complicated setup I think
ours to think that were these two chairs
are gonna go within five minutes of like
me coming back and us setting the chairs
up and then just going back to grab her
bag before heading out to dinner yeah
like someone had snuck in and totally
like taken Josh's bag taking Jessica's
bag
yeah and idiot didn't know where
minimalists yeah
that's so funny but actually here's the
irony of that if you take my bag you've
essentially stolen everything I own
[Laughter]
including my passport so I'm Canadian
now yeah and so Ryan and I go looking
around the neighborhood and see what we
can find and obviously you can't find
anything and I I can tell you I felt
this amazing sense of Xin lei there was
just this letting go and I was truly
surprised by my reaction to all of this
like all of this wasn't happening to me
and it was just happening and I was
witnessing it and the the feeling of I
tell you the feeling of letting go and
the ease of letting go I certainly
wouldn't have been able to do seven
eight years ago I would have been just
yelling and pissed off throwing [ __ ] and
it was just all gone and then this the
sound in here is really good tonight
right they're doing a great job and
that's because of Bo who's back there he
also found the person who stole our bags
and Bo beat the [ __ ] out of him
no I'm just kidding we don't advocate
violence a he got the police involved
then they arrested him and and we got
our bags back and that was pretty great
so it was good to be Canadian for a
while yeah and but no it was all
everything back except Josh's shirt yeah
you know I don't I'm wearing than
wearing this shirt for several days now
yeah everything was returned besides
that I mean I think Jessica's lifetime
supply of manuka honey was in there her
cauldron I have no idea what she keeps
in that bag supplements yeah yeah but uh
it
it's nice to be back in Canada yell we
have a lot of answers so if anyone has
any questions you can step on up that
microphone let us know your name where
you're from and what your question is in
that order
ideally hi I'm Janelle I'm from here in
Vancouver did you know thank you guys so
much for coming I'm really stoked to be
here thanks for being yeah thanks for
being first we appreciate that I ran
down here from way at the top yeah it's
kind of coincidental that you brought up
that exact subject that I wanted to ask
about and I've been thinking about this
question stolen passports Club Oh a
stolen very valuable item you know we're
a big city I'm sure this happens in
every big city but bikes get stolen
every day all day and for some people
like myself it's the way we get around
it's the way we get to work to school
all the things and it's really hurts
right when these things happen and I
just wonder if you've thought especially
Ryan you know I miss nowhere like you
are those things mean a lot to you you
go through so many memories with them
and you know you really kind of connect
with those things even though there's
still things like have you thought about
what would happen and how you would deal
with that if you had that really kind of
prized item stolen from you because it
does to bring a lot of value to your
life yeah I mean the thought of it
totally which I just want to say
something real quick before I answer
this question I love Vancouver faker was
beautiful I was just joking about the
foggy comment don't hold that against me
speaking of snowboarding like Grouse
Mountain when it is when it's pow-pow up
there it's awesome like it's yes it's
not bad um no I did scare the hell out
of me think about anyone stealing my
mountain bikers snowboard yeah that
would suck but you know at the end of
the day though it's not it's not the
emotional attachment to the thing as
much as it is to the experiences so man
uh my so Moriah my partner she had her
bike stolen a couple years ago and it
was super sentimental to her and like
she was
really bummed out but it's replaceable
and we did replace it and actually she
had like a little cruiser bike and I got
her a mountain bike which was great cuz
then like she can't take the cruiser
bike up on the hill with me so it worked
out yeah it worked out really well for
us to replace it with a mountain bike so
now we're able to create even more
memorable experiences and have more
adventures but you know I'll say earlier
today when all that's even the passports
that got stolen
I just remember I'm like walking around
and I'm just looking for someone with
bags which by the way I like I'm looking
for just Jess's bag and Josh's bag but I
have no idea what I'm gonna do if I find
this person I'm like what if I did do be
like excuse me I think this robot he was
walking around shadowboxing looking
menacing and as I'm walking around I'm
thinking to myself I'm like man Jess's
computers in there her passport was in
there
Josh's passport was in his bag I thought
maybe his computer was in there too
turns out it was at the hotel room which
is great but like all this is going
through my head and I'm like man I sure
hope like Josh didn't have any books
that he was writing just on his computer
and wasn't like you know putting it in
the cloud somewhere as backup but you
know as I'm like having this you know
tornado of thoughts going around I
really did get to a point where I'm like
all of this is replaceable I'm like none
of this is as life-threatening and I
really thought to myself I'm like wow
this is a really this is like a true
test of our whole philosophy isn't it
because I know like I don't know if jess
has any other bag except that backpack I
mean I'm pretty sure like the majority
of what she is using on the tour is in
that so even then I'm like alright we're
going to like go find her some you know
some clothes to replace the clothes that
she lost and you know if we need
absolutely have to get laptop so we can
figure it out but yeah I don't I don't
really hold on to the
the physical object as as the memory or
as like the the sense of adventure that
I get so if it got stolen from me I
would suck I'd be bummed out I have a
longboard that has like all types of
stickers yeah at longboard
actually yeah you you guys love long
boarding here in Vancouver
even I thought missus will love long
boarding like this place is way more
down with the long boarding but my
longboard has all these stickers all
over at like friends who are in bands
who are like hey here's a sticker and
I'm like sweet I'll put this on my
longboard or we're at the Fillmore in
San Francisco which is like just an
iconic venue like such an honor to be
there I mean Hendrix and the Grateful
Dead and Joplin and like you name I'm
just naming old like hippie bands but
there's been plenty of other bands there
too but like seriously if you can think
of a band they have probably played at
the Fillmore and and sold it out and
they gave us like you know backstage
passes and like I put that on the bottom
of my longboard so there are all these
like really cool you know mementos I
guess that I have sticking to the bottom
of my longboard and I've thought about
I've went through this exercise with
like what if someone is sold this
longboard I could still tell the story
without the longboard you know so I
guess that's what that's that's really
kind of my short answer is it doesn't
matter what someone takes from me like I
still have the story yeah the only thing
I'll add to that is that I was surprised
by the lack of emotion well you were
surprised by your lack of emotion all
right I didn't I didn't deploy my one
emotion no the the emotion that I felt
was inconvenience
because I was like damn I really liked
that passport picture
I look like a Russian spy on it it
barely looks like me every time they
like go through the TSA or whatever they
look at it they look at me in their way
and you just look at him you're like
what are you talking about
[Laughter]
I was but here's the good news like in
or maybe it's bad news I don't know when
they called and said they found it I I
didn't feel like overly overwhelmed with
joy or anything either because it's also
stuff and I don't I saw you you you
don't want the you don't want the love
of stuff right and thus when something
comes back into my life like it's good
and I enjoy it I'm grateful I'm
especially grateful for Bo for you were
everything that he did to find it and I
I can tell you that the I felt joy the
where I really felt the joy is I could
see the panic on Jess's face and the
only thing I could do when everything
was was losses go through and give her a
hug and say we're not hurt and that's
what's important thanks to the question
hey there howdy what today Laughlin I'm
from Kamloops boat hey we met earlier
Alfred yes I actually the thing that
went through my mind when we you came
out and gave us a hug was like man he
seems really chill considering his
passport just got stolen so right on man
thanks um so yeah I just wanna say
thanks first of all for making it up
here you guys's message is just such a
breath of fresh air so thank you so much
thanks man
it's our pleasure so my question is I
listen to your guys's podcast and you
always talk about curating your life for
your things or whatever and you know
what comes to mind for me is sort of
like a you know a you know a fancy art
dealer curator guy and but instead of
paintings it's you know the things
relationships hobbies that you have in
your life and if a piece doesn't really
fit in with your collection anymore it's
time to get rid of it and I just wanted
to get both of yours you know opinions
and dive deeper into that what that
means for you guys and sort of your
process for curating things yeah I think
I think a museum is a good synecdoche
therefore for life in general because
what we're talking about curation you go
to a museum they the ones that are the
most influential or leave the lasting
memories they give you a particular
feeling it's not just like well I saw
the Picasso painting and I've checked
that off my list now there's a place
called the Dali Museum in Saint
Petersburg Florida
and they they built a new one I think in
2011 and it looks like Dali
the museum itself looks like Salvador
Dali had a dream and it melted into this
building and it's it's stunning and I
can tell you that I can I can verbalize
it but what makes it stunning is the
details and I think it's the other 1% of
attention to detail the curation the
bringing not just the beautiful things
but the
appropriate things into your life the
useful things into your life and and
doing so well here's a short answer for
you restraint is beauty and I think that
I think that if we're able to restrain
ourselves from constantly bringing in
the here's another short thing for you
[Music]
we moved into the lightning round
apparently I think the bones are the
beauty and I think that the minimalism
boil something down to its essence yeah
I I think it's fun man curating stuff in
fact like my partner Mariah and I when
it comes to painting specifically you
brought that up so I'll talk about that
a little bit I mean that's really fun
for us to kind of pick out what we're
gonna put on our walls you know it's
funny like when we're doing an interview
or something like the reporter or who
are like whoever will ask us so we're
like what is it just like stark white
walls no furniture and I'm like no it's
not it it's like yeah I'm like no it's
not like that for me for some minimalist
it is and that's great but you know
Mariah and I like we really do love to
have to have art and I have I have a lot
of friends who are artists and I'll tell
ya if it wasn't for Mariah I actually
probably would buy more art but like and
he'd time I buy a piece I'll send her a
picture of it and I'm like hey this
looks really cool like is this something
that you would be down to haven't and
you know she's not you know really
excited about it then I'm not gonna
force that on it I'm certainly not gonna
buy it and just put in a storage
somewhere so I'll pass on it um but you
know I think the curation process it is
it can be rigorous I guess and
definitely disciplined but I think that
it can also be a lot of fun too and we
step back and you look at a well curated
our collection or life in general like
it's it's a really really good feeling I
just had one of the things so we're both
moving to Los Angeles this month
and I just moved there two days ago my
partner Rebecca met me there with the
u-haul and it was not the 26 foot truck
it was it was a little box sort of
tethered to the back of our truck it
just you know with a hitch and we are
we're trying to bit of an experiment
this this next year or whatever however
long it is I don't know the timeframe
but we're trying an experiment on slow
acquisition because we're not gonna just
fill this new apartment that we're
renting I mean you go there it's a white
box you can see you can go to my
Instagram accounts just uh what is my
Instagram account
Joshua Milburn no that's not a you're
instagramming it's a baseball player I
think oh yeah yeah it's Joshua fields
Melbourne there we go
but if you like baseball anyway yeah so
so it's a white box right now and we're
very slowly it's much easier to there's
another pithy thing for you it's much
easier to or it's much easier to curate
when you own less there we go
thanks thanks man thank you
hey guys how you doing out state what's
your name brother
awesome my name's Matthew I'm actually
from a little place called Surrey which
lots of you guys know a bit of a running
joke here in Vancouver I actually I go
to school in Vancouver and I were have
we met before I don't believe so
okay never mo so I go to school in
Richmond and I work here in Vancouver I
spend hours on transit I just got to say
your guys's podcasts have made those
trips a whole lot more bearable and have
added so much value to my life and I'm
sure many other people out here in this
crowd then thank you so much it's gonna
sound so weird when you're listening to
our podcast and you're listening to
yourself that's exactly what I was
thinking I'm gonna think it again
I first found you guys on Netflix and I
absolutely fell in love with it started
packing away clothes for my closet but
Ryan you said something at the start of
tonight that I really wanted to that
actually gave me the question you
mentioned an intentional life you know
you guys have also said purpose and I
was wondering kind of a two-part how did
you guys first come to live a purposeful
and intentional life and how would you
suggest someone like myself or anyone
else out here to get to that point as
well it's simple man you just quit
school and start a blog now don't do
that I'm getting secret yeah it reminds
me so Sean sent me podcast Sean who he's
really the man behind the minimalism he
is our tour manager he is our road
manager he's our podcast producer our
podcast editor our website editor our
book editor email responder and
everything else we don't want to do Sean
does yeah and all around and he's he
runs all the operations for the
minimalists all-round outstanding guy
ladies and gentleman podcast Sean I
think the shadows
and he sent me this some audio to listen
to he's I thinking you take a look at
this before I publish the this episode
of the podcast and it was a couple
months ago and so I'm walking through
the good food store Missoula Montana
listening to our podcast because he will
asked me to write it's the only podcast
Josh listens to the only books he reads
are ours yeah I just a more coy sitting
on a bench with everything that remains
no I'm walking through there I'm
listening I'm like buying its
ingredients for a smoothie and this
person walks in hey I love your podcasts
I'm like thanks I really appreciated
like I have really been getting a
podcast and I'm like yeah me too and
they go are you listening to the one
right now yes what are you listening to
I listen to a bunch of different
podcasts it's hard for me to lie so yeah
I just left it there anyway Ryan what is
an intentional life to you yeah man I'll
tell you when I so when I was in the
corporate world driving from Dayton Ohio
done this Cincinnati were like the main
office was it was on a really crappy
like traffic day I was probably going
hour and a half drive maybe two hour
drive and I remember being stuck in
traffic and it was at a point where like
the alcohol and drugs weren't working
anymore I mean just the lifestyle was
living it was I mean it was just coming
to a head and so first piece of advice
is find enough pain to make yourself
want to change so like I was
experiencing that pain of like oh crap
like I don't know I don't know what I'm
gonna do like I hate what I do now I
don't see any way out of it and all my
pacifiers are not working anymore and I
just remember thinking I'm like man if I
could just find a way
to contribute to as many people as
possible like I don't care if I live in
a shack I don't care if I live in a
mansion I just I really want to do
something that's meaningful to me and it
kind of stemmed from what my role was at
the time I mean I was managing I was
managing store managers and teaching
their employees how to sell like small
office Home Office blah blah blah but
what was really cool about it is that
these sales guys especially like on the
on the ground floor like I could I could
go to someone who was getting ready to
like I was getting ready to you know
have fired and I could have a
conversation with them they like look
I'm not we're gonna fire you like your
boss is we're going to let you go unless
you can kind of turn it around like how
can I help you turn this around and then
like watching that person go from being
fired to being Employee of the Month
like that to me was like the best
feeling in the world like having that
type of effect on someone so you know
I'm in traffic I'm just you know
thinking to myself like how is there a
way that I can just contribute beyond
myself in a meaningful way and this was
this was before minimalism before Josh I
even asked him that you know question of
why the hell are you so happy but what
I'll say is is is that stuck with me and
I know that that's kind of a cliche
thing like dude I just want to help
people man but it was true like that's
it that's the thought that I stuck with
and um I didn't really you know I did I
didn't expect this day I mean this is
amazing that I mean this is a beautiful
accident that you know Josh and I are
able to go on the road and tell our
story um but what I'll say is when Josh
introduced the concept of minimalism to
me that's where I was like oh wow like
if oh yeah like it was common sense it
wasn't this
it wasn't groundbreaking it was more oh
the this these are people living common
sense lives but they're actually like
walking their dirt or walking the talk
or you know they're actually doing it
and for me it was yeah if I don't have
this huge mortgage if I don't have if
I'm not if I don't buy a new car every
couple years if I stop going out and
buying the latest upgrade maybe I don't
have to spend as much money and
therefore it all have to work as much
and I can start reclaiming some some of
my time to figure out what I am actually
passionate about or you know something
that I can do that feels much better
than you know what I was doing at the
time so it was really a you know kind of
a slow transition between that but I
always held on to that one to that one
thought of like how can I add value to
as many people's lives as possible and
then after the packing party that's when
I went to Josh and I was like this is a
beautiful way to like add value to other
people's lives like this whole journey
this whole story I think will resonate
with a lot of people and I continue to
just cultivate that you know I mean that
first that first year when I got laid
off we I made like twenty three thousand
bucks
I hadn't I've never been happier I've
never traveled more like I traveled so
much that year and it's not like I
didn't leave the corporate world with
with millions of dollars I had I had
like four to six months of bills saved
up and you know it was enough to like as
a safety net but that that following
year was just an amazing experience and
I just continued to cultivate through
all the drudgery through all the I mean
this is like the first legit tour we
have ever been on man I mean we used to
have to like call the venues I don't
know if anyone has ever tried to book a
venue in another state let alone another
country like it isn't just like hi I'd
like to have your venue this day and
time great see you then bye I mean it is
it is not that easy and yeah I mean
there were there was a lot of hard work
but what I did is I stuck to that
feeling of how can I contribute beyond
myself in a meaningful way and as long
as what I was doing the net result was
was doing that then like I felt really
really good about that so I guess to
give you like a like a
answer because that's I mean that's a
very specific recipe that you know I
don't think anyone could really
replicate but certainly there are some
ingredients there but in broader terms I
think you know find something that that
interests you that you really that moves
you that makes you feel worthy of doing
whatever it is and put everything into
it I mean that does that does not mean
to quit school and start a blog that is
the worst advice anyone could ever give
you man oh but but what I will say is
that if there is something that
interests you that you don't have to
quit your job and then do that like you
can totally start doing that while
you're working it's really a matter of
how are you gonna prioritize things so I
would say find something you're
passionate about and then prioritize
your life in a way where you can focus
more on that and put everything that you
have extra into it I would just say that
a meaningful life is a life in which
your shirt the short-term actions are
aligned with whatever your values are
and so get really really really really
clear on what your values are but that
said the the second thing I would say is
a meaningful life is also filled with
failure and so get out there and fail
some more and if you're not failing a
lot then you're not failing enough mmm
the best way to get good at failing is
you you practice thanks brother
appreciate it thank you guys so much and
I'm a hugger too so I'll see you guys
after the show and yes you will that's
great all right before we move on stay
put for one second here for the people
listening to this at home by the way
Ryan yes tell you something
and I think if my math is correct
because as some of you know this is a
math podcast in Canada it's a maths
podcast this is episode 100 of the
minimalist podcast get out of here
Wow so for those of you listening at
home if you have a comment or a tip for
anyone who asked a question today then
you can leave us voicemail four zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine or
just send a voice memo right from your
phone to the email address podcast at
the minimalists comm we will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode Ryan what time is it it is time
for our hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning around where well we usually
answer questions from social media but
since you guys are here it's a theme
yeah we'll go ahead and answer your
questions were you John Twitter actually
no let's just go to Twitter right now my
phone we're usually on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook at the
minimalists think we're thankful for
jessica lynn williams over here ladies
and gentlemen she helps us run all the
social media especially while we're on
the road we're still on there
interacting with folks all the time but
she curates all the the posts and the
timing and makes it all look beautiful
so thank you Jessica appreciate you and
instead of going to Twitter let's answer
your questions we usually do this with
140 characters or less but since we're
in front of a live audience we'll mandar
on a bit until we get something well
usually I make like a week to prepare
yeah but since we have only a few
seconds yeah we'll have to yeah I would
you know welcome thank you thank you for
bringing value to my life I the last few
months I've decided to basically
everything that you've said get rid of
things think about changing my life Paks
no way way is it everything I said
everything Ryan said well it's a little
bit of both because I moved back to
Vancouver from Thailand and we moved
into six hundred square feet and I
decided everything has to fit with no
storage boxes so that's where I am right
now
right but part of my process has been
that I feel guilty for I don't know
getting rid of this stuff and now that
my life is changing and I'm starting to
think that there are other option
than what I'm used to living what do you
feel guilty about specifically
well now I'm thinking I could do
something else other than the career
that I've had before doors are opening
that had an open before and it's a
little bit I think overwhelming but I
feel guilty I don't know how to explain
it I don't know if you guys went through
that sure I don't think guilt is the
emotion that you're feeling right now I
I understand why it because it feels
really similar to what you felt in the
past when you have felt guilt and I I
grew up Catholic so I'm acquainted with
guilt and I think the the emotion that
you're feeling right now is anticipation
and it may may be bordering on
excitement even I can tell you that
there are before we go out on stage to
give our talk or whatever I start to get
like sweaty hands and my heart starts
beating really fast and and and then
then of course I get to get a little
lump in my throat and the tight tight
chest and I start to tense up a little
bit I know I'm so nervous and then I'll
look over Ryan he goes I am so excited
right now excitement and stress
manifests in your physiology the exact
same way and so quite often we think we
are anxious or we're feeling guilty or
whatever there there's often a positive
emotion that's on the other side of that
and maybe just maybe you're feeling that
I think that's 140 characters
yeah whose counts perfect right on thank
you oh by the way Jessica set up a a
website called minimal Maxim's so all
these little pithy answers we just put
it out there and she live tweets from
from the show usually as well so if you
use the hashtag less is now she will
show have all the pithy stuff on there
and also not so pithy stuff I think man
I'm trying to come up with a real nice
pithy answer to this guilt is such a
funny emotion because it's valuable to a
certain extent like yeah no it is
you know if I'd let's say I oh let's say
that Josh and I are supposed to meet in
the lobby at a certain time and I'm a
half hour late that would never happen
and Terrano three days ago yeah um it's
like you know I'm like oh like I you
know fell asleep and that you know I all
this guilt of like oh man like I'm a
half hour late this is I'm I know how
much it stress is Josh doubt but like
sort of feel guilty then it's very
useful emotion to feel guilty now is
pointless like that right now for me to
look back on that and feel guilty is
that doesn't do anything for anyone
all it does is well make me feel guilty
and it's dan Harris talked about in our
documentary about how when you're
running late to the airport you know
it's it's really important that you have
this awareness that you have to get to
the airport at a certain time but to sit
there and stress yourself out about it
is is useless
rumination it there there is a point
where guilt will serve a purpose but
there is also a point where it will it
is just useless rumination I think maybe
my pity answer would be Josh help me out
here I'm calling I'm calling front no no
I got it
I would I would say something like
you know ruminating in guilt of the past
is the worst waste of your time there's
one of the worst ways yet to waste your
time thank you
howdy how are you outstanding how are
you which name Stephanie I'm from
Virginia quite the drive Bravo I came
all the way I just drove DC's a little
bit closer
I know DC to BC so I drove 3600 miles to
move to Victoria oh wow yeah welcome
and also when I found out you guys were
touring I was like I must go there
I must go - oh thank you so anyone else
here from Victoria nice we try to do
that do it again this time around but it
just it didn't work out we did Victoria
a couple years ago sorry well we will be
back we promise so I just wanted to let
you guys know that you're a huge
inspiration for my move I I'm a dual
citizen so about a year ago I quit my
job not you know it was just because I
wasn't happy and I decided to move to
Canada because the west coast I just
wanted to live out here because of 2016
hey we had a really hard year
so I essentially gave up 80% of what I
owned and at that part in my life at
that time I didn't think I even had that
much 5 bags to the goodwill later right
um so I packed everything in my car and
it fit it was like catalogued and
organized and I drove through Canada and
was incredible and you drive down the
one oh yeah oh nice and the 17 in
Ontario and 417 in Quebec but it's an
honor being here I guess my question is
for both of you guys what is your
favorite book or online resource that
has helped you kind of thrive in the
minimalism lifestyle that you hold dear
to you so so this isn't gonna be a very
beautiful pithy answer you can't answer
with the minimalists com
why there are three books I'm trying to
decide between one of them and they're
available in the lobby afterward no in
all seriousness that they are available
out there but it's not meant to be funny
if you didn't bring a wallet and or you
just can't afford one we'd be happy to
buy a book for you if you want one just
pass it on minimize it afterward when
when you're done with with the book it
does no good collecting dust on on a
shelf in terms of books that have had a
lot of influence on me I mean that there
are quite a few I start out writing
fiction and I never anticipated writing
nonfiction at all so there are some
authors that like Jonathan Franzen and
David Foster Wallace who I've had a
tremendous impact on my life the person
who made me want to write nonfiction or
write memoirs in particular was Mary
Karr
she has three great books liar's club
cherry and lit she also has a great
non-fiction book called the art of
memoir
and in terms of like minimalist living I
go way like I look way back at the old
texts of the Stoics epictetus is my
favorite and so he has a book or he
didn't actually write the book it's from
his lectures that one of his students
transcribed it's called the discourses
and it's 80% useful and those useful
bits are a hundred percent beautiful
guys saying more remark as a really as
fan personally I'm gonna give you a
documentary there is a Tom Shadyac
documentary called I am and that that is
what I can't remember when I come out
like right as the minimalists came out I
think I think it was yeah like 2011 it
was right around the same time yeah but
I remember like that when that so for
those who haven't seen it Tom Shadyac
well for those of you who don't know who
he is he did like Ace Ventura and what
else
liar liar liar liar a lot of Jim Carrey
movies really like famous Hollywood guy
and he went through this whole
experience of having a concussion which
you know changed how he had to live his
life and then he realized like oh wow
like I'm really just doing this because
I feel like this is what I should be
doing rather than actually doing what I
want to do um but I remember when that
when that documentary came out if you
haven't seen I am like you got to see it
it's amazing it just it was for me it
was the affirmation of like I am NOT
crazy
like we we actually are onto something
and it was yeah I was just like one of
the most encouraging pieces of work that
that I've had like through this whole
time I could list off some books to
stuff but I think I am is like
definitely a must see he did a follow up
is it called happy I haven't seen it I
haven't seen it either how it is they're
all we just mentioned a bunch of stuff
Sean I'll put that all on the show notes
since we didn't have anything pithy for
you thank you so much thank you thank
you
hallie hi
what's your name Heather Heather I'm
from Pitt Meadows and I love your
podcast thank you makes my commute
awesome my question tonight is about
minimalism and parenting so I my
question is how can I work through
impressing minimalism on my children
while respecting their very young their
attachment to their things how many kids
- how old five and a half and three okay
and I don't want to pun intended
minimalize their feelings or during the
process so yeah I think I think it's
important so Ryan you don't have kids
what's your advice minimize the kids I'm
just joking no you know I think as as I
don't know it's job-stealing was from
Joshua Becker cuz I don't have kids so
yeah it's very easy for me to give
advice on who will be at our Phoenix of
any yeah he will be at our Phoenix event
but he's got he has this book out called
clutter-free with kids have you ok so
you've seen this so in the book he talks
about there's one line that really stood
out to me about how you know as parents
you don't want to and you can't you know
control your kids but you do have the
ability to set boundaries and I think
that is is where it starts one example
is a it was someone in our audience I
forget which city it was but she was
talking about how when her daughter will
come home she's like five or six years
old and has like a piece of artwork and
she's like hey I want to put this on the
refrigerator and she's like the mother
was like you know I hate to tell my kids
no so what I do is I tell her yes so I
guess we can absolutely put this on the
refrigerator they walk over and like the
refrigerators already covered in art so
she's like alright well which one would
you like to take down and throw away and
then like the kid has to make this
deliberate decision of like okay
this one's old news I don't like this
one anymore we'll go and get rid of this
one we're gonna replace it with the new
one and I think things like that is what
really is empowering for kids because
yeah you don't want to just minimize
their feelings that is certainly true so
I think you know when it comes to
parenting the question is is you know
how can I set boundaries for my children
and still respecting their their
feelings and emotions and I think that
when I sew sew backs my partner and I
we've been working with Ella on saying
yes to her a lot because it's always
with a little kid I mean ever since she
was two I've got really good at saying
no with everything no stop no just stop
it and and instead I save those nose as
if like I have a short supply of them
and I want to be able to use them so
when I do use it it is more effective
because she just hears no all the time
then it becomes this amorphis blob of
nonsense and so now I I will say yes and
and we've gotten really good you know
can I have a cookie yes you can have one
this weekend if you do this this and
this right and I didn't mean for that to
be funny but apparently it was so so
here's the thing
III work really hard to say yes and save
my nose for when they are are most
appropriate and the other thing that I
worked really hard to do with Ella who
by the way is on Twitter at Ella
sandwich for those of you would like to
follow along her her childhood one
obnoxious tweet at a time
she today's tweet was like a whole thing
cataloged on my phone of all the things
she says today's tweet was I'm hungry
all the time even when I'm sleeping
that's how I feel and care for a cookie
that's the problem yes and I will so so
the thing that I try to do is Challenger
and have have discussions around around
things and she's four years old so I
understand she's not going to understand
many of the concepts or even words that
I'm using with her and that's okay but I
continue to challenge her but while I'm
doing that it's also challenging me
that's pithy write that down shot thank
you all right before we move on thank
you thank you thank you before before we
move on how many more people do we have
over there if you had to count seven all
right can we grab four for a bonus
podcast which we're going to record
exclusively for our patreon numbers in a
moment but first I want to move on to
something called an added value segments
I have to apologize to three people that
want to sit down right now I'm really
really sorry I promise you'll get a
extra tight slow-dance hug from Ryan
afterward we'll hold on the four people
will try to be quick with their question
but first we need to move on to an added
value portion the shows where Ryan and I
each recommend I don't even recommend we
talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently and since we
are here in Vancouver we might as well
recommend something that we love in
Vancouver Ryan what has added value to
your life in Vancouver man I love so
many things in Vancouver um you say the
fog is one of them
I even loved the fog um man
well first off I'll say what I really
appreciate about Canada and well I think
Vancouver more so there aren't a ton of
chains like it's not like like gold
chains yeah not a ton of gold chains
also their honor telling like a
restaurant chains like there it's not
like Fridays Applebee's you know all the
other like major core like there are so
many mom-and-pop places and to me like
what that means is like there are a lot
of passionate people in Vancouver and
they yeah and they and and I just I
really respect that
um so many places recommend uh Bandidos
have you guys been there at all yeah the
place is awesome it's gotta be one of my
favorite places the not just in in
Vancouver but in Canada yeah
unbelievable oh so good um matchstick
coffee is go beautiful well he stole
what I was going to recommend and if you
haven't been to if you're a snowboarder
well actually I'm assuming you have been
a grouse mountain so I'm not gonna
recommend that but if you haven't taken
you know if you're not a snowboarder and
you haven't taken the what do they call
that thing the gondola up to the top of
the mountain you live in Vancouver go do
that for crying out loud and actually
I'll write how many okay so how many
people here are like from BC originally
alright alright awesome how many people
have never left BC you live in [ __ ]
Canada man get out there
it's a beautiful place it is so gorgeous
whether you go BAM are you kidding me
you haven't been to Banff oh my goodness
I'm so I'm recommending to local places
and then I'm wrecking Canada to Canada
hey guys you ever been to Canada well
Ryan stepped on my added-value but I
will try to pick it up and dust it off
here Ryan and I opened a coffee shop
last year and one of the reasons we did
it is we are really passionate about
connecting people and and sometimes
providing a space and we found some
folks that we could do that with it's a
place in in st. Petersburg Florida
called bandit but we've gone all over
you know we've done 100 city tour in
2014 we this is our eighth tour in seven
years and it's really just a great
excuse for us to find really great
coffee and I can tell you in the top
three you're definitely in the top five
coffee shops on the continent you have
one here and it's a place called
matchstick coffee it's over on 15 yeah
yeah give them a go check it out if you
haven't already it's it's truly amazing
the aesthetics are beautiful I mean talk
about curation they do an outstanding
job great service great people great
place and just outstanding coffee so you
can check that out it's called
matchstick let's move on real quick to
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist if you didn't notice we're on
a tour right now so 40 cities we're
called the less is now tour and you can
find all the dates to that if you're at
home listening to this all of Canada
sold out so Bravo Canada we love you to
Canada
but there are still some tickets left to
a few cities in the United States a
bunch of them sold out less is now calm
one city that hasn't sold out yet is
Houston and I'm gonna bring that up in
particular because there is well there's
a lot going on in Houston right now so
it's pretty understandable that they're
not buying our tickets but here's here's
the thing whenever a tragedy strikes
Ryan and I believe that that giving is
living and it sounds like a trite truism
but it's true it's just it just is true
and so contribution is part of living a
meaningful life and so in Houston right
now there are a lot of people suffering
over 100,000 houses have flood in fact
our coffee shop down in st. Petersburg
Florida we're getting ready we did is we
got photos today that it's all boarded
up because the next hurricane is getting
ready to hit Florida now and so we had
to close and and board that all up but
that's nothing compared to what's going
on Houston right now and if you've seen
the photos of the flooding and and the
the people and it's a bunch of people
have died as well but the rebuilding
efforts there are going to take years
and so we've partnered up with a
nonprofit called GlobalGiving
and if you get a chance for those you
listen to us at home you want to attend
our Houston event 100% of the profits
from that event on November 5th go to
GlobalGiving
now they're doing a couple things
they're putting that money toward the
relief efforts right now because you
need medicine and food and shelter and
immediate assistance but the second half
which we often forget about is long-term
rebuilding it's gonna take years to
rebuild there's gonna be a lot of
problems with the humidity and mold and
all this other stuff and so it's gonna
cost a lot of money and so they need
they need whatever help they can get and
we found there's three ways you can help
one is you can attend that event if
you're anywhere local or you want to
come down and ten have been a hundred
percent of the profits are gonna go to
GlobalGiving number two is you can
donate directly to global giving and you
can just go to the minimalists comm
slash
Harvie which is the the hurricane Harvey
and you can donate directly from there
whatever amount you want Thanks
and thanks to you we're able to do a lot
of cool stuff like that where we've had
opportunity to build schools or to fund
other charities in the past and it's not
because Ryan and I are some supreme
altruists it's because we've been able
to connect with a lot of awesome people
who are willing to contribute as well so
thank you so much for that and also one
last thing to mention here is all of our
sponsors right this is the time we
recommend the mattresses and I've been
finding trouble sleeping at night you
need new bedding you know three
presidents have slept on this bedding
who else can we mock I don't know let's
a lien eight ourselves even more from
the podcast anyway we're fortunate
enough to and this is weird to say we
have one of the largest podcasts in the
world and that was also a beautiful
accident we never intended to do this
long-term it was a fun little thing to
do while our documentary was was coming
out and then it's turned into something
completely different but we refuse to
take advertisements because
advertisements don't align with our
values personally it's not us knocking
anyone else who does it and there are
actually good ways where you can use
advertising on your platform it's
difficult but it is possible to do so
deliberately but because we are a
hundred percent advertisement free we
asked for some help from our audience
we're looking for one percent of our
audience to contribute two bucks and and
the way that works is Ryan and I are
building a podcast and film studio in
Los Angeles none of the money that is
donated to our podcast goes to me or
Ryan directly it all goes to help build
this podcast studio so we can invest in
more meaningful creations we want to do
a lot more video work because we were
really shocked by how much the the
documentary that we put out resonated
with people people of all ages we've had
a lot of teenagers and college kids come
in the events and all the way up to
people in their 90's
showing up at events and saying they saw
the documentary so we want to do more of
that one do short video creations video
essays vlogs all kinds of stuff that we
can put out there but we can only do so
if we have your help so if you want to
support us we're doing something called
patreon it's you just go to the
minimalists com click on the donate
button at the top you can contribute one
time via PayPal or per episode via
patreon if you contribute on patreon
we're doing we've been doing this every
single week now for the last what month
month and a half something like that you
get a separate podcast feed that shows
up right in your regular podcast feed
however you listen to podcast called the
minimalists private podcasts and what
we're doing is we we sort of do an
overtime episode for every episode that
we're going to record and we're gonna do
that right now here with a live audio so
it's gonna be like private plus there's
good you have four or 500 people here
tonight and then whoever's listen to
this and the private podcast feed and
you get access to that if you contribute
to to the patreon account so we have
some questions here Sean this is what
you'll like fade to black or something
and then we'll turn this into a a
special private podcast and now back to
our regularly scheduled podcast welcome
back actually you know a couple things
there from from the overtime thing we
were just recording Ryan I was just
joking about the whole cult thing that's
jokes I just I want to make sure for the
half of you who were dragged here by a
friend or family member and like not to
get the impression that like there's no
Dogma I'm not trying to convert anyone
to minimalism tonight but we do have
certificates available out in the lobby
[Laughter]
no and the the thing with relationships
that that last question there on on the
the private podcast I think I think
sometimes I think I think it's okay to
be unattached to a relationship and what
I mean by that is
is willing to walk away always be
willing to walk away from a relationship
My partner Rebecca and I we talk about
this all the time and make sure that
like is this what we still want because
it's fine if you want to go sign a
marriage certificate and put a ring on
your finger or whatever but but that
doesn't equal real commitment real
commitment is being willing to show up
every day and and show that other person
that you care about them they care for
you and you can be each other's
caretaker I mean I think love and a
certain to its a certain extent I think
love is is just two people wanting the
same thing for more than a moment and
and so you're constantly re-evaluating
do I want to be in this do our values
align and if the answer to that is yes
then you can emphatically run toward
that relationship and if the answer is
no you can ask yourself why and can i
repair this so that we don't just drift
apart
that's what happened in my marriage in
my 20s I first took the person closest
to me and we drifted apart we had
different goals we had different
outcomes we had different values I
didn't even realize until we were so far
apart it didn't even matter anymore
and so sometimes I don't advocate being
attached to someone I I have a K being
committed through those daily actions
hey before we wrap this up I just want
to say thanks to the Rio Theatre of
Ravan is here tonight
and there's one other person I want to
thank tonight actually two other people
only think bow again for saving our
passports thank you bow yeah man way to
pull through and most important I want
to thank you I want to thank you for
being here tonight you pay some money to
get in and that's great because we used
to have these events in like coffee
shops the first one we had in Vancouver
I [ __ ] you not was on a patch of grass
in a park July 2012 is there anyone here
from that I'm just curious
yes that is so freaking awesome in that
is killer that is so cool
and it's great cuz we got to go out and
listen the reason we could tell the
stories we do during our talk our talk
that we give it the first 45 minutes of
this thing is because we went out and we
listened to a lot of people when we told
different stories you found out what
resonated what didn't resonate and then
we'd end up sleeping at a rest stop or
occasionally if we got lucky on a
reader's floor or something and so you
paid some money to be here tonight so we
could actually sleep in a bed tonight
before we get up at 4 a.m. and head to
Calgary tomorrow and it allows us to pay
Sean and Jessica and all the staff here
and security and have an awesome venue
with a roof and everything and we really
couldn't have done that without you
tonight well mainly because we'd be
speaking to a bunch of empty seats
anyway um you also gave up too far more
precious resources tonight your time and
your attention and we're really grateful
for that and if you leave here tonight
with just one message well actually
we'll be out there afterward in about
twenty minutes you can come get a hug as
well if you want but if you leave here
tonight with one message we hope what's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
being here thank you Vancouver thank you
so much
[Applause]
hi Joshua and Ryan my name is Kelly
I'm calling from Hampshire Illinois and
I just had an answer for Leah on episode
99 on her question with marriage and
minimalism and I just wanted to say um
as well as her I would like to have a
small wedding one day um but it's a
little difficult because it costs a lot
of money and it usually involves a lot
of stuff but I just wanted to give her
the idea she hasn't thought yet having a
backyard wedding is I feel one of the
most simple and cheapest ways to go my
mother had one and it was really fun and
we were able to use a lot of the
decorations and uh after the wedding so
yeah I just wanted to let her know that
backyard wedding are pretty awesome my
name is Betty I'm from upstate New York
I have a message for Jean the woman on
your podcast about building a tiny house
and she was looking for ways to minimize
her kitchen I recommend looking into an
instant pot it's all in one pressure
cookers slow cooker rice cooker yogurt
maker I it's best if you youtube or
google it rather than listen to me rave
about it but it sure saves a lot of
station
it saves on extra appliances Josh Ryan
my name is Nick cozy and from Evansville
Indiana and I just been listening to
episode 55 on critics and I just wanted
to share a quote that I heard from my
friend and he got this from his grandpa
and it's all one of my all-time favorite
quotes now and it is don't take
criticism from someone you wouldn't take
advice from and so I just wanted to
share that because it's a great quote is
something that I live by now I have some
stream and I thought that a lot of
people could get value from that quote
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be fine
without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine
without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]